bonsoir et bienvenue pour une nouvelle
édition de municipales 2014 sur TVfil 78
je recevrai dans un instant Daniel
garçon candidat divers gauche à
Saint-Cyr-l'École actuelle conseillers
municipale de position il a reçu le
soutien du PS pour cette campagne
également en plateau tout à l'heure
Christian Nicole Gaëlle Gesbert de la
liste sans étiquette génération
solidaire qui se présentait en cours ils
évoque un projet citoyen nous parlerons
aussi des relations entre l'UMP et l'UDI
et puis bien sûr toutes les dernières
informations politiques première invité
de municipale 2014 Daniel garçon bonsoir
bonsoir et lui à Saint-Cyr dans
l'opposition face aux mers UMP Bernard
de bain à la tête du groupe
Saint-Cyr-l'École avant son ensemble
vous serez candidat en mars sous
l'étiquette divers gauche oui mais avec
le soutien du parti socialiste on va
acheter un coup d'oeil sur les résultats
de 2008 dernier scrutin municipal la
liste socialiste était une liste PS la
seule liste de gauche avait totalisé 34%
des suffrages exprimés qu'est-ce qui a
changé depuis 2008 pour vous permettre
cette fois-ci de remporter la campagne
aujourd'hui ce qui a changé
c'est peut-être le travail préparatoire
qu'on a fait depuis un certain nombre
d'années et puis une situation
particulière à Saint-Cyr que que l'on
voit avec force division à droite et
puis une démarche aujourd'hui on n'est
pas sur simplement une liste présentée
par le Parti socialiste on est sur une
démarche que j'avais un petit peu
expliqué la dernière fois que je suis
venu vous voir
je suis élu depuis le début de la
mandature je me suis aperçu très vite au
bout de deux ans que tout ce que je
pouvais proposer aussi bien en
commission quand on conseille municipal
n'avait aucune chance d'être retenu
parce que simplement j'étais
l'adversaire j'étais l'opposant et donc
je me suis dit ben sur cette mandature
il va falloir faire avec mais en tout
cas je veux pas continuer à faire de la
politique comme ça mais ça veut dire que
si vous êtes élu vous ne ferez pas la
même chose ah si je suis élu je ferais
pas la même chose mais mais ça l'écoute
aussi des listes d'oppositions ça me
paraît tellement évident que on doit
être à l'écoute de 100% des
Saint-Cyriens si on a quelque soit la
couleur politique qu'on soit à droite
qu'on soit à gauche une fois qu'on
arrive aux affaires on écoute moins son
opposition oui mais ça c'est la règle
générale et moi je veux pas faire de la
règle générale donc je me suis préparé
depuis 4 ans avec l'association avant
son ensemble et on a essayé de
structurer une réflexion et on a essayé
d'associer un certain nombre de gens ça
a commencé par des présences dans les
quartiers sur des thèmes très forts
quand l'occasion était nécessaire mais
aussi par des ce qu'on appelait des
mensuels et on se voyait une fois par
mois un groupe de 30 40 personnes pour
analyser une position de la ville pour
analyser une délibération pour analyser
une thématique donc aujourd'hui au bout
de deux ans on a 30 à 40 personnes qui
connaissent chacun 20 à 25 aspects de la
vie politique de l'urbanisme de
l'économie de l'école du social donc ça
nous permet aujourd'hui de présenter une
liste certes d'union de la gauche parce
que moi je suis gauche je vais pas le
premier c'est avec les communistes aussi
vous êtes en discussion le Front de
gauche aujourd'hui on est en discussion
comme vous le dites on a déjà deux
réunions de discussion mais j'ai pas
j'ai pas d'appréhension le Front de
gauche on a été dans le même groupe
d'oppositions durant toute cette
mandature et jamais nos positions n'ont
été divergentes en conseil municipal je
dis pas qu'on est toujours d'accord mais
on a toujours su trouver la voie unique
de la gauche qui parlait en conseil
municipal donc aujourd'hui c'est un
petit peu normal le Front de Gauche
c'est diverses c'est plusieurs
regroupements c'est le parti communiste
le PG les gens vont faire vont faire
leur avancée par eux-mêmes moi la
campagne allait lancer j'ai écrit en
août à l'ensemble des forces de gauche
de la ville à l'ensemble des élus que je
souhaitais continuer mon travail de 6
ans de mandatures que je souhaitais
soutenu par avançons ensemble m'engager
sur une nid d'union de la gauche que je
souhaitais être le meneur de cette liste
et que j'allais me lancer dans la
campagne à l'horizon septembre-octobre
le Parti socialiste le MRC on réagi ils
m'ont dit Titus on vous suit parce que
on travaille ensemble depuis six ans
parce qu'on travaille ensemble dans
l'association on y va comme ça avec
l'étiquette du PS c'est aussi conseiller
on sait période un petit peu compliquée
au niveau national c'est mieux de se
présenter sous une liste d'unions de la
gauche je vais pas je vais pas dire que
c'est facile de se présenter avec une
étiquette PS mais je le dis d'autant
plus facilement c'est que je suis pas
membre du Parti socialiste moi je suis
né à s'inscrire jamais été je suis né à
Saint-Cyr-l'École il y a 56 ans j'ai
militait dans les milieux associatifs
dans les milieux sportifs et j'ai
toujours été de gauche et aujourd'hui au
delà de c'est ce que j'ai expliqué à
Bernard Debin en conseil municipal
au-delà de notre opposition homme de
droite homme de gauche c'est pas
suffisant pour que je me présente face à
lui parce que si c'est simplement ça le
débat on pourrait prendre n'importe quel
homme de gauche qui pourrait incarner
moi je veux représenter autre chose et
je lui ai expliqué que notamment sur les
derniers affaires l'école Bizet par
exemple je ne supportais plus sa façon
de faire préciser pour les
téléspectateurs qui n'habitent pas tout
seul à l'école ou peut-être ceux qui
habitent aussi sincères à l'école ce
qu'est cette histoire autour de cette
affaire de cette école business une
école qui était vouée la destruction et
qui finalement sera réhabilité on
pourrait peut-être préciser les choses
c'est l'une des plus vieilles écoles de
Saint-Cyr donc c'est un bâtiment qui est
ancien et à un moment où nous explique
que il faut la réhabiliter que ça va
coûter un million moi je suis pas un
spécialiste des BTP mais un million pour
rénover un groupe scolaire j'y crois pas
je dis monsieur Debin c'est pas possible
un million vous vous trompez c'est
simplement pour acheter la peinture
deux ans après on nous explique que
effectivement faut pas la réhabiliter
faut la raser mais comme la vie n'a pas
d'argent on va vendre le foncier de
l'école et on construira une nouvelle
école or moi je sais très bien qu'on a
de l'argent puisque je regarde les
finances municipales et j'ai pas du tout
qu'on vende le foncier et donc je dis
monsieur Debin vous ne pouvez pas
détruire cette école ou simplement le
fait de dire elle est en mauvais état on
la détruit ça ne me suffit pas et là
dernièrement au dernier conseil
municipal d'octobre Bernard Debonne nous
explique que on va plus la détruire
qu'on va la réhabiliter moi je supporte
plus on peut pas changer d'avis comme ça
tous les 6 mois sur des sujets aussi
importants vous parlez du foncier c'est
un des enjeux de cette campagne de
savoir ce de quoi faire de tous ces
terrains de toutes ces constructions qui
sont menées sur cette ville de
Saint-Cyr-l'École lorsqu'on passe dans
cette commune on le voit il y a des
nouvelles constructions des nouveaux
immeubles tous les six mois des nouveaux
chantiers qui sont lancés moi je pense
qu'on a perdu le contrôle de l'urbanisme
à Saint-Cyr-l'École aujourd'hui on est
des prix d'accession à plus de 5000
euros le mètre carré ça veut dire que
aujourd'hui
peu de personnes peuvent accéder à la
propriété et donc on fait la part belle
aux sociétés civiles immobilières qui
achètent place et qui loue ça amène quoi
sur la population saint-cyrienne un
turn-over très important et un manque de
fidélisation dans nos structures nos
milieux associatifs n'arrivent pas à
renouveler leur cadre avec des nouveaux
habitants nos milieux scolaires pareils
et donc la querelle elle est pas nouveau
saint syrien ancien saint-cyrien c'est
évident qu'une ville à la besoin de 109
c'est évident qu'une vie de la besoin de
se développer en position ce n'est pas
d'arrêter toutes les constructions sur
la ville à ma première proposition moi
c'est de prendre la maîtrise de
l'urbanisme il y a plusieurs moyens
techniquement envisageables ça va de
l'appréhension au périmètre de
sauvegarde déjà c'est ça et puis il y a
surtout la volonté politique et le
dialogue qu'on peut avoir avec les
aménageurs aujourd'hui quand on prend le
projet de la ZAC Charles renard 24
hectares 1400 logements la ville mais
zéro euro donc comment voulez-vous que
la ville puisse dire je ne veux pas ce
type de logement je veux plus de mixité
je veux plus d'accès à la propriété à
3002 30006 3008 le mètre carré elle ne
met pas un centime
aujourd'hui on a un en début 2013 on
commence l'exercice financier avec 11
millions d'euros sur un budget de 24
schématisa
soit la ville allait entièrement équipée
on n'a pas besoin de nouveaux
équipements et à ce moment-là on baisse
la pression fiscale et on n'a pas besoin
d'avoir 11 millions soit la vie elle est
pas assez équipée ce que je pense et à
ce moment-là on utilise les 11 millions
11 millions c'est à peu près un an
d'imposition
taxe d'habitation taxe foncière bien
personne ne peut avoir 11 millions c'est
tout sauf de la bonne gestion quel autre
proposition vous faites aujourd'hui
est-ce que le programme est complet
est-ce que les listes aussi on va y
venir sont la liste est complète non
aujourd'hui le provoque principaux de
programme le programme n'est pas complet
un programme ça se construit pas un
groupe de 30-40 personnes même si c'est
30 40 personnes travaillent ensemble
depuis deux ans dans un programme on
donne des fils conducteur premier fil
conducteur bloqué l'urbanisme parce que
là il y a vraiment urgence et deuxième
fil conducteur qu'est-ce qui doit
diriger qu'est-ce qui doit mener la
réflexion à Saint-Cyr moi pour y être et
pour l'avoir vu se construire petit à
petit le fil rouge c'est l'enfant tout
ce qui doit être fait à Saint-Cyr doit
être placé autour de l'enfant on doit se
poser la question est-ce qu'on augmente
un groupe scolaire est-ce qu'on augmente
l'offre de service sportive culturelle
est-ce que l'urbanisme doit être conçu
comme ça ou autrement comment on place
l'enfant au milieu de toutes nos
décisions ce sont les deux axes je
dirais principaux parce que tout va
s'accorder autour de ça tout quand on
discutera ou quand on évoquera des
circulations douces forcément on le
pensera parce que les poussettes les
enfants bas âge en vélo devront pouvoir
les emprunter pour aller de leur école
de leur résidence au lieu de
au lieu d'équipements tout ça ça se
pense autour d'un fil conducteur
aujourd'hui il y en a pas c'est de
l'emporte-pièce une dernière question
elle concerne la situation à
Saint-Cyr-l'École on va pas refaire tout
l'historique ce soir on n'aura pas assez
de temps mais la situation politique a
toujours été compliquée dans cette ville
aujourd'hui on a assisté il y a une
quinzaine de jours au départ de trois
membres de la majorité de Bernard de
bain 3 un nouveau membre de cette
majorité qui ont décidé de rejoindre une
opposition de centre droit menée par
Étienne erasimus qui sera d'ailleurs
candidat à cette élection ce sera l'un
de vos adversaires qu'elle regarde vous
portez sur cette situation et ce
déchirement entre les différents départs
moi je vais pas mêler de ce qui se passe
chez mes adversaires politiques
à droite et ça peut me profiter je vais
reprendre non non je vais reprendre
c'est compliqué à droite aujourd'hui
Bernard de bain alors qu'il a commencé
la mandature avec 25 conseils municipaux
il a fini à 18 ça veut dire que il n'a
plus qu'une seule voie de majorité mais
au final que ce soit la candidature des
résimus la candidature de Gaetane
Desjardins la de Bernard de vin ces
trois listes de droite c'est pas mon
c'est pas mon souci moi j'ai un souci de
faire une liste divers gauche avec une
conception différente de la politique
socialiste le candidat en 2008 c'était
Marc sa doudoune il a disparu depuis
c'est la vie ça arrive ça arrive on
vient on arrive il y a des situations
particulières que vous connaissez pas et
que je n'ai pas été arrivé sur cette
commune de Saint-Cyr pour prendre la
commune de Saint-Cyr ça c'est pas passé
comme prévu ça c'est pas passé comme
prévu mais c'est parce qu'il y a motivé
son départ mais peut-être qu'en privé je
pourrais vous expliquer merci Daniel
garçon d'être venu sur ce plateau
candidat de la coach avec le soutien
donc du Parti socialiste sur cette
commune de Saint-Cyr-l'École
reste encore à Saint-Cyr-l'École
quelques minutes avec un autre candidat
à le représentant du centre droit
Etienne erasimus il peut compter dans
son équipe sur le soutien d'anciens
membres de la majorité du maire sortant
les tensions les divisions qui semblent
donc de mise dans cette campagne voici
ses explications au micro de Claire
Cambier dernier épisode en date
effectivement mercredi vous l'avez dit
lors du conseil municipal ou trois élus
de la majorité de ce qu'il reste de
majorité de Bernard de bain nous ont
rejoint au sein de ce groupe je rappelle
quand même que ça fait 11 départs depuis
le début de la mandature depuis 2008 qui
sont symptomatiques d'un malaise et d'un
manque de vision comme je le disais et
le but effectivement est de réunir et de
rebâtir un projet qui puisse fédérer les
sensibilités du centre et de la droite
sur Saint-Cyr absolument
et pour cette campagne qui débute nous
lui avons demandé ce qu'il entendait
mettre en avant les principaux points de
son programme les grands axes je dirais
par rapport à cette ville de Saint-Cyr
qui est quand même je dirais malmené
depuis plusieurs années c'est de lui
redonner un avenir avec gérer trois
grands axes de travail et d'action selon
moi le premier c'est offrir à la
population un niveau de service et un
accompagnement qui soit conforme à
l'évolution de la ville et justement à
l'évolution de la population de
Saint-Cyr parce qu'elle a beaucoup
changé à la fois en quantité en qualité
nous avons toute une nouvelle population
dont il faut tenir compte donc
accompagner cette évolution premier axe
deuxième axe maîtriser l'urbanisation
parce qu'on a vraiment une impression
d'action en matière d'urbanisme au coup
par coup mais pas d'action menée pensée
de manière globale donc là il y a
urgence à réagir par rapport à cet
aspect d'urbanisme et de préservation du
cadre de vie ça me paraît très important
et puis un troisième axe qui est
absolument essentiel et qui conditionne
d'ailleurs la réussite des deux premiers
c'est bien évidemment le développement
économique qui est quand même le grand
délaissé de cette ville de Saint-Cyr
aujourd'hui il faut bien le reconnaître
on quitte Saint-Cyr-l'École on
s'intéresse à l'UMP dans les Yvelines
qui entend renouer les liens avec l'UDI
après un communiqué de presse voici une
dizaine de jours par le représentant des
centristes dans le département le
députuteur Nourrichard qui appelait au
dialogue voici qu'elle le parti de
droite ce manifeste à son tour dans les
mêmes termes c'est également par un
communiqué que l'on apprend que Valérie
Pécresse chef de fil de l'UMP loca la
mandatess Sophie prima Gérard Larcher à
langournac et Jean-François rénal pour
négocier un accord avec l'UDI député
sénateur conseiller généraux pour
enfants se mettre d'accord sur les
investisseurs en vue des prochaines
élections municipales évitez au maximum
que les deux formations de s'opposant
mars et ne perdent ainsi trop de voix au
passage les tractations qui vont donc se
poursuivre et puis autre information lui
ne vise pas une mairie c'est
Jean-Frédéric Poisson que l'on aurait
pourtant vu à Rambouillet avec le départ
de Gérard Larcher il annonce se préparer
aux élections internes du parti chrétien
démocrate après le départ d'une autre
tribulinoise Christine Boutin qui
préfère se concentrer sur les
Européennes et son combat contre le
mariage pour tous les militante du Parti
chrétien démocrate se prononceront le 9
novembre prochain entre l'actuel député
des Yvelines et un adhérent des
Hauts-de-Seine responsable commercial et
marketing d'un groupe industriel
français
je reçois donc à présent dans cette
seconde partie du municipal 2014
Christian et Nicole et Gaël j'espère
bonsoir à tous les deux et tête de liste
et numéro 3 de génération solidaire à
Élancourt la moyenne d'âge c'est 24 ans
sur votre liste qu'est-ce qui a poussé
qu'est-ce qui vous a poussé à vous
engager en politique on va commencer par
la tête de liste bonjour nous pensons
que nous avons des idées pertinentes
pour pouvoir les amener au niveau de
toute la commune et surtout que nous
pouvons changer un peu la manière de
faire la politique dans une ville ou
peut-être certaines disputes et
certaines ambiance ne sont pas les plus
intéressantes pour la vie des élans
courtois actuellement vous êtes étudiant
salarié qu'on connaisse un petit peu
jeune professionnel d'accord que des
jeunes professionnels nous avons aussi
des étudiants nous avons des personnes
plus expérimentées nous avons certains
retraités des mers de famille des pères
de famille nous avons des personnes qui
nous soutiennent il y a des personnes
qui nous conseillent alors qu'ils ne
pourront pas être eux-mêmes sur la liste
et nous avons des personnes des voisins
des amis des présidents d'associations
qui eux nous donnent leurs avis nous
donnent leurs conseils nous disent ce
qu'ils souhaitent voir la manière de
faire la politique qui nous on va dire
qui nous soutiennent nous disent que
c'est un bon mouvement que c'est
intéressant de ne pas avoir d'étiquette
et d'essayer de se focaliser sur
Élancourt plutôt que d'essayer de plaire
à tel ou telle partie ou d'essayer de
regarder les enjeux nationaux vous
n'avez jamais été engagé auprès d'un
parti politique chacun
alors ça dépend des personnes dans la
liste des personnes qui sont allées voir
parfois à droite à gauche mais la
plupart des personnes s'intéressent à la
politique sans être vraiment engagé et
ce qui nous semble important d'un point
de vue municipal ce n'est pas tant
l'engagement au niveau national et plus
l'engagement auprès des élans courtois
pour essayer de réaliser avec eux des
projets concrets pour améliorer leur
quotidien pour pour améliorer la vie à
Élancourt ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui c'est le cas nous avons une
ville qui est quand même qui est quand
même intéressante à vivre et c'est aussi
pour ça qu'on se présente parce que nous
sommes élancourtois depuis de nombreuses
années que c'est une ville qui nous
tient à cœur c'est une ville qu'on a
envie de voir encore grandir pourquoi on
peut pas rejoindre la liste du maire
sortant alors si vous êtes plutôt
satisfait du bilan de Jean-Michel
fourgon alors d'abord parce qu'il est
souvent compliqué pour des citoyens
ordinaires ou pour des membres
d'associations d'intégrer des listes
qu'ils aient qui existent déjà et
ensuite parce que nous étions tout un
groupe parce que nous avons discuté avec
des voisins des personnes expérimentées
et que beaucoup de personnes hésitent à
aller rejoindre des partis politiques
déjà formés et comme je disais qui
regardent souvent des objectifs
nationaux plutôt que simplement
municipaux alors que nous notre objectif
va être d'aller voir les élans courtois
au maximum à la fois au troc à la place
du marché chez eux via le site internet
ou alors via des médias pour essayer de
leur demander leur avis leur opinion
leurs sentiments sur ce qu'il
souhaiteraient sur leur vie des
quartiers sur tout ce qu'on peut leur
apporter ou tout ce qui peut leur être
apportés par une mairie mais qu'est-ce
qui monte actuellement à l'heure de ces
différentes consultations que vous avez
commencé à faire attendre
il faut quand même on peut quand même se
féliciter qu'ils sont pour la plupart
d'accord avec le fait que c'est une
ville assez bien gérée par contre ils
aimeraient tous plus ou moins améliorer
les relations entre les personnes les
relations entre les quartiers je pense
que cette amélioration d'ambiance s'est
amélioration du quotidien pourrait
amener Élancourt à être encore mieux à
vivre dans la vie de tous les jours d'où
le fait que nous mettons tellement en
avant ces valeurs de convivialité et de
solidarité qui pourrait permettre en les
faisant mieux vivre dans notre ville de
retisser ces liens et ses relations
entre personnes surtout avec avec une
optique de vivre à Élancourt de rester
Élancourt alors même qu'on nous propose
de partir à l'étranger à Paris ou autre
mais ça se traduit comment dans un
programme justement cette notion de
convivialité de solidarité
alors on dévoilera notre programme petit
à petit dans les prochains mois
pour toi et pas seulement l'éducation
par exemple cette réforme il y a des
rythmes scolaires le maire sortant
Jean-Michel fourgon s'il l'a dit sur ce
plateau qui s'y oppose il boycotra la
mise en place en 2014 vous en pensez
quoi alors c'est une réforme qui peut
être intéressante à mener
on peut apporter des choses en plus aux
enfants il peut y avoir des choses à
faire toutefois elle est difficile comme
pour la plupart des communes françaises
elle demande un budget qui n'existe
généralement pas dans les communes donc
c'est quelque chose qui pourrait être
bien à faire et à mener la question à se
poser c'est est-ce que les moyens sont
suffisamment donnés aux mini aux
municipalités pour la mener à bien nous
mettons vous êtes élus en mars vous
faites quoi ensuite pour septembre 2014
elle rentre en vigueur ou non cette
réforme dans votre ville si on est à la
mini cépérité elle sera probablement
mise en oeuvre parce que forcer pour
toutes les municipalités de France nous
nous conformerons à ce aux obligations
d'une municipalité ensuite il faudra
savoir comment la financer et ça nous ne
souhaitons pas voir nous ne voulons pas
augmenter les impôts comme pour la
plupart des autres listes et il faudra
trouver alors les moyens les endroits où
faire des économies comme les dépenses
somptueuses ou autre qui profitent
peut-être pas à tous les élans courtois
et qu'il serait alors peut-être plus
pertinent d'orienter vers les enfants
vous pensez à quel type de dépenses des
dépenses qui peuvent être on va dire
tourner un peu plus vers la
médiatisation vers la communication que
vers l'intérêt de chaque élancourtois on
va se projeter deuxième tour vous
réalisez un score convenable au premier
mais vous n'êtes pas élu vous faites
quoi dans notre dossier
on s'est mis d'accord sur le fait
d'aller voir les différentes clés pour
voir au minimum que tous les projets qui
ont été apportés par les élans courtois
pourront être accueillis au sein de la
future majorité que ce soit le PS ou
l'UMP qui passe nous ce qui nous importe
c'est que les projets qui sont amenés
par les élans courtois tous les
meilleurs projets que nous aurons
travailler préalablement puissent
réaliser et se concrétiser ça veut dire
quel que soit la couleur politique PS ou
MP ou négociera ou pas je ne suis pas
certain que les formations sera ouverte
à on va dire à cette éventualité par
contre ce qui nous intéresse vraiment
c'est que que l'on soit ou pas dans une
future majorité c'est que les projets
soient réalisés mais c'est aussi pour ça
que nous faisons une campagne la plus
ouverte mais aussi la plus proche du
terrain possible allez voir chaque
personne pour discuter parce que ces
projets n'auront vraiment une
crédibilité que si un maximum de voix
nous est attribué donc on a besoin de
leur confiance et je pense qu'ils
pourront nous là nous l'a nous
l'accorder si on est demain à notre but
n'est pas seulement d'avoir un projet
qui est celui d'une liste donc d'une
quarantaine de personnes mais vraiment
d'avoir un projet qui soit élancourtois
qui soit celui de la réalité des
différents quartiers qui soit celui de
la réalité du quotidien de de chaque
élancourtois ni gauche ni droite mais
pour autant vous pourriez soutenir un
des deux candidats si on se projette
psump voir FN parce qu'il y aura une
liste Front national normalement sur la
commune de l'emploi alors nous avons
décidé tous ensemble de ne pas Salier à
un éventuel lors de deuxième tour avec
des extrêmes mais par contre nous
négocierons pour possiblement avoir des
postes dans l'exécutif au niveau du PS
ou de l'UMP donc en plus offrant non
operse à la personne la plus réaliste
quant aux projets qui seront menés par
les élans courtois encore une fois quand
on va voir toutes les personnes dans
leur quartier dans leur dans leur
commerce ou autre on va les voir en leur
disant qu'on est là pour essayer de
porter des projets et pour essayer de
les réaliser au mieux donc ce qui nous
importe puisque beaucoup on va dire
j'imagine un peu le monde politique et
ils ont peut-être pas tort on ne dit
jamais certains de savoir à quoi
s'attendre de connaître la crédibilité
des personnes à qui on parle et ça c'est
quelque chose d'important c'est pas
parce que quelqu'un va nous promettre
beaucoup de choses c'est possible que en
contrepartie n'exécutera aucun des
projets ça ce n'est pas notre objectif
notre objectif c'est vraiment d'arriver
à réaliser les projets quitte à ne pas
avoir vraiment de poste ou alors en
avoir très peu vous n'êtes vous n'avez
pas le soutien pardon de parti politique
on l'a bien compris pour l'instant
comment vous financez votre campagne sur
fond propre c'est à dire nous mettons
une partie de nos salaires on est en
train d'aller voir des amis des voisins
des parents on essaiera de demander
campagnes politiques ça coûte assez cher
tout à fait on ne regrettez pas
l'investissement pour l'instant jusqu'à
présent non parce que c'est aussi un
réel ça montre aussi notre réel
engagement pour Élancourt et notre envie
de devoir Élancourt grandir comment ça
va s'organiser pour la suite de votre
campagne afin de connaître votre liste
complète quand et tous les différents
points de programme quand alors la liste
est encore ouverte à des personnes
c'est-à-dire on a de quoi on va dire
présenter une liste aux municipale
toutefois des personnes y sont pour
permettre à ce mouvement d'exister et il
ne serait pas compte se retirer si des
personnes encore plus motivées si les
personnes avec plus d'idées ou avec plus
d'implication souhaitent venir souhaite
porter leur projet leurs idées dans les
dans cette course aux municipale et en
tout cas en allant voir les élans
courtois ou en allant voir directement
le maire ou les autres partis politiques
donc dans cette dans cette optique là la
liste complète sera dévoilée
probablement en février merci à vous
deux candidats donc le génération
solidaire et encore une liste sans
étiquettes pour le scrutin de mars sur
cette ville d'Élancourt c'est la fin de
ce numéro de municipale 2014 prochain
rendez-vous sur téléfil 78 donc un jour
les programmes qui se poursuivent sur
tvfils